bienvenue à montigny échos city une
ville 100% en matériaux recyclés un
projet créé par des jeunes ni mon teint
à l'occasion des trophées régionaux de
la robotique
on n'a rien acheté pour fabriquer la
maquette jusqu'à la guirlande qui a été
récupérée au niveau des encombrants et
ça donc voila et des briques de lait qui
nous ont servi donc à faire les
immeubles et on a travaillé donc autour
de ce projet avec une centrale nucléaire
qui est gardé par un dôme indestructible
et qui permet donc de d'éviter les
retombées radioactives
je trouvais que c'était intéressant de
toucher à alex callinicos il électriques
et de bricoler 37 équipes ont participé
à cette édition des jeunes de 7 à 18 ans
issus de toute l'île de france
organisée par planète sciences le
trophée demande plusieurs mois de
préparation
le thème cette année at home factory ça
permet de toucher à beaucoup de choses
que ce soit de l'électronique pour
certains ça peut même aller par des
petites notions de programmation et ils
travaillent sur leurs robots en équipe
donc ça fait aussi travailler avec les
autres travailler à plusieurs et 7 à
développe aussi des petites compétences
de bricolage elle lésigny montendre
parts de cette édition avec le prix éco
citoyen les vainqueurs eux ont rendez
vous les 6 et 7 avril pour la finale
nationale à saint quentin dans l'aisne